what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time with
wall street's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right i am here
with polina she is in uniform let's get
it rocked in
don't forget that lunch money is not
sponsored by block five go to block five
dot com slash pomp and you can get a
block by account
where you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy in that interest bearing
account or you can sign up for the wait
list
of the credit card so let's go to
blockbuy.com
pomp what's up economy time all right
what is happening the u.s economy is on
track for a boom with the federal
reserve predicting last week that it
would expand by
6.5 percent this year that would make it
the that would mark the fastest growth
since 1984 when ronald reagan was
serving his first term as president
but a survey of the country's top
economists
uh shows that many in the field are
still worried about what could be coming
down the pike
a majority of the 205 members surveyed
say that they believe risks to inflation
are greater than those seen in the past
two decades
for all you who are like what inflation
no inflation
talk to the top economist in the country
bill
gross the co-founder of pimco believes
that inflation's gonna hit three to four
percent the next couple of months but
the federal reserve believes they are
not going to
raise interest rates which would be a
way to combat inflation so all
i'm saying is that i'm not saying that
it's going to happen but i'm saying you
better be prepared in case it does
happen
most respondents said they were
concerned about the trajectory of public
debt only 12 percent said they weren't
scared at all
almost two-thirds of respondents think
the fiscal deficit should be addressed
by enacting policies that
spur stronger economic growth meanwhile
meanwhile more than one-third favor
exercising greater spending discipline
or increasing taxes stay strapped
is all i will say all right i wrote
about it this morning oh did you
yeah oh somebody didn't read it
go ahead next you know i was trying to
sleep because then i didn't sleep really
well so i was trying to sleep
next all right apple and epic are
nearing their highly anticipated
fortnight trial
and plan to bring forward some top
executives
to testify in person the case concerns a
fallout between the maker of one of the
world's most popular video games epic
and apple's control of its app store
epic assuming apple for alleged
anti-trust violations what do we think
here
i think that apple's going to get in
trouble because apple what apple's doing
is wrong
what is apple doing they're price fixing
they say you have to give 30
and these guys said no i don't and then
they give deals to some people but not
to
everyone and i think that ultimately
what's going to happen is they're going
to say you can't do this
they're preventing competition but
because apple was like you know a
company
can't they say i want to deal do a deal
with you like that and i'll deal with
you like that
and you can except for if you're a
monopoly and what basically epic
realized was that they had a monopoly on
this and so therefore what they're going
to do is they're going to expose
the monopoly and that's what they do
apple used to be the challenger and now
apple is not the challenger it's like
the
every pirate you live long enough
to either die or become the man that's
how it works pirate
open sea has been one of a handful of
nft marketplaces to explode in
popularity in recent weeks as collectors
have waded into the trading of
non-fungible tokens on the blockchain
so there's nifty gateway there's openc i
thought that uh
yeah i think you might have talked about
this but we're gonna talk about it again
sorry right now cody what up
we're cody look tell us more
ricottie is a pseudonymous artist who
reached out to me
and i've partnered with absolutely
killing it
two drops uh that they've done over the
last two weeks have been fantastic
uh the doodlemon open seas so uh i'm a
big fan of the openc
platform all right let's talk about this
story
facebook is looking into creating an
instagram for kids
uh it is exploring the possibility of
building a version of its popular video
and photo sharing app for children
younger
than 13 what could possibly go wrong on
this platform
because right now i think if you're over
18
or you have to be 18 to start a couch i
think you have to be like 15
or 17 14 so it says um
increasingly kids are asking their
parents if they can join apps that help
them keep up their friends
right now there aren't many options for
parents so we're working on building
additional products
like we did for messenger kids that are
suitable for kids managed by
parents i don't know what do you think
i just don't know okay let me just tell
you a little something something a
little story about paulina discovering
the internet when i was like
nine we had just moved to the us i was
on the internet discovered this um
chat called like chat one or something
sketchy
and i was in there and i was reading all
these conversations between people and i
was like oh my god this is like
this is like not appropriate no imagine
those kids i should not have been on
that platform i wasn't doing anything
inappropriate but
went to a porn setting she was not the
fact that i had access to these chat
sites uh social media platforms i just
think that
you know let's let's hold off uh kids
under 13 can do other things play some
you know roblox
what do you think i think that uh they
will figure out the
safety tools but but how do you prevent
creeps from getting on this
but they have ways they have ways to
prevent it i'm more worried about what
it does from a psychological standpoint
to kids it basically makes them feel
like uh you know they've constantly got
to do things to uh
impress their friends that type of stuff
next
chimps from two czech zoos or zooming
each other
every day he loves a good chump story
all right
we humans may be tired of zoom calls but
these two chimps at two czech zoos are
just starting to enjoy their new live
online link up to okay so let's see what
they do
they're 93 miles away and they can now
watch one another's daily lives on giant
screens there are no mute button
disasters as the sound is off but there
has already been plenty of interest
at what the distant cousins are up to
since the project got underway last week
yeah they they uh they basically just
look at each other they make little chip
moves and stuff
in the screen that's fine i'm more
interested not in the chimps that are
zooming with each other but the fact
that redditors have adopted 3
500 gorillas baby gorillas yeah
google it right now just type in reddit
gorilla adoption
and uh when you think about this i saw
somebody tweet it
and yep there you go right there reddit
investors adopt 3 500
uh 3 500 gorillas in less than a week
which
uh somebody quote retweeted on twitter
and was like what are they planning now
i think that they raised money uh oh so
you can like
virtually yeah i think i i don't think
that is anything too too crazy but the
headline was like
reddit investors adopt 3 500 gorillas a
process by which a donation is made to
the fund in the name of a specific
gorilla to help oh should we donate no
okay what's the next where where's the
point what has moist been up to this
weekend
all right i got two minutes i got things
to do hold on a second
first of all it's ask lunch money time
hashtag ask lm in the comments below
khao san we have a question greetings
from canada big fan of your show and
both of your amazing newsletters
to me you guys are the best ny couple
sorry jay-z and beyonce
all right my question today is not
bitcoin nor finance but to know the
three favorite local restaurants in
miami
dominoes or golden arches do not count
pomp ps
when will joe from huddle up guests are
on the show the best pompliano brother
in my opinion
same here same here this is the best
most perfect comment
oh i only like this comment because you
said hashtag motor
let's roll hashtag mamba mentality
hashtag the profile huddle up ask lm
good this is model this what are your
three favorite restaurants
okay mr 01 the pizza place dimitrios
demetrios is a mediterranean place and
casa tua
bang bang bang bang y'all weren't ready
for that i would i would switch
constitute out
for um belly sushi
that's a pretty good one too all right
that's it mr 01 by far though is our
number one favorite that is not it
i was trying not to talk to moist today
go ahead were you mad at moist or
something no
you just weren't hurrying up and i got
things to do day 26 so i think this is
day 27
uh pat mcafee is tnf commentator is a
no-brainer espn banning their employees
from going on a show might be the woke
straw that broke the camel's back
also have a hunch that austin texas is
where you flew out to
wait no i did not oh i hope i'm right it
depends on what i'm doing but most
likely i'm going with the athletic
shorts because they will show off my
calves the best
i have never heard of this athletic
shorts and khakis hybrid
that you mentioned i had neither moist i
have no idea what he's talking about
what i don't remember a question i asked
but uh for let me clear something up i
did not go on joe rogan's show oh guys
it is somebody in that sphere but you
will find out tomorrow because oh is it
tomorrow's
yes um but
on top of that moist i have
two questions for you
okay please don't sing oh we don't need
to hear this today
moist what's the best rap song of all
time do not mess this up
the number one your favorite rap song
of all second question did i say i have
two questions yeah
okay that's a good one if you were on a
stranded island
and you had one hamburger what from
mcdonald's
and paulina and i were both there who
would you give it to
moisture
let's see let's see where your loyalty
lies big dog
let's see i'm not going to read your
questions if you don't pick me
let's see moist all right turquoise palm
this is gabriella's brother
is saying hey i am ready for ready for
whatever you bring me moist i might be a
kid but i
am strong so don't underestimate me
hashtag ask ellen he has a question does
punk play video games if so what is your
favorite game mine is roblox or mario
i used to play mario kart i would run
around and throw the bananas
you know i'd do that a little bit and
then uh my favorite games though were uh
were definitely the sports games i
personally i liked uh madden i used to
smack everybody anybody who plays uh
video games you play madden you're
losing to me just
l you just put the l in the l column
immediately
uh i was good i was great guys i wasn't
even good or great i was the best
all right uh let me tell you one but uh
turquoise palm
you can come over here i'll stuff you in
a locker give you a swirly if you wanna
play video games but other than that i'm
a really nice guy
but if we play video games it's going to
get dangerous real fast
you ever played video games and had [ __ ]
talk to you at the same time probably
not this is a 12.
oh my god 12 years old great you had 12
years to get ready for me but i will
destroy you in videos i have a feeling
he'll destroy you but let me tell you
guys what is this kid gonna do try to
make me play a game that i don't know
how to play that's the only chance
you've got and guess what i don't play
games i don't know how to play i only
play the games i know how to play and
the games that i had to play i never
lose
he he gets weirdly competitive with
video games i've only played him one
time at an arcade in north carolina
played was is you're giving yourself way
too much credit it was four of us
and it was mario kart and it was four
boxes and i was one of those boxes
except i was so bad at it that
i thought that i was like bottom left
box so i kept looking i was like oh my
god i'm so good i'm so good i'm so good
and then i didn't realize that i was
actually supposed to be looking at upper
right because that was
what i was and i was just like stalled
in a ditch
all i'm gonna say okay is that she took
that just like you 12 year old
i listen you know what i need to do this
week it would be a huge boost to my ego
if i
smack the 12 year old in some video
games i will stuff you in a locker real
quick
fine i'll give you a swirly no problem
all right that's it for lunch one day
today
i like everybody if you're 12 if you're
20 if you're gabrielle if you're moist
if you're wet you're soggy whatever
see you guys tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends